Thank You Aaron on further the
introduction and thank you all for
coming
it's certainly warmer here than outside
today so it's a good place to be but
we'll see what to top this so I I faced
the title as a question
clustering there is very help I won't
give you the answer till the end but I
should tell you I'm a theoretician so
but actually I'm a skeptical
theoretician hopefully you'll see and
maybe that provides the clue so first
let me define what clustering is and
then tell you something about it so
clustering as you probably all of you
know is just the problem of doing the
following you are given n objects and
you want to divide them in this talk you
will partition them so strictly each
object will go into one cluster there
are softer versions of these but for
concreteness we'll focus on this
partition them into K clusters K is
sacred is going to be throughout the top
the number of clusters each cluster
intuitively should consists of similar
or closeby objects and we'll define them
in a minute
so for this talk and for quite a bit of
the applications and theory each object
is a vector that's all so it has one
component for feature if you will and
there are many features so each object
is a very high dimensional vector
ready the number of dimensions is as
many as the number of features that you
put it
that's one complication to remember that
these are high dimensional vectors so in
some sense problem is a lot easier if
they were in two or three dimensions but
that's not the case and we could measure
either the similarity between objects
for example if they're vectors dot
product is a notion of similarity or
cosine of the angle is another
of similarity all we could measure
distance dissimilarity most of the top
will measure distances and these are
just purely clearing distances they're
vectors in space and the distances are
just Euclidean distances now to sort of
introduce part of the title theoretical
computer science or theoretical
operations research for instance focuses
on the following question you find an
optimal K clustering an optimal division
partition into K parts now optimal means
one of many possible things one
possibility is that you minimize the sum
of the distances of each data point to
its cluster center so when I'm done
clustering I have some K clusters each
data point belongs to a cluster and it
has a center you measure its distance to
the center perhaps sum them up this is
not the only possibility we'll see there
are several other possibilities or you
could maximize the similarities within
clusters if you are given similarities
so you could have any number of these
our objective functions perhaps for
concrete as again we'll focus on one
thing which is the k-means problem where
you minimize not the sum of distances
but there's sum of squared distances to
cluster centers it's an interesting
phenomenon that in theoretical computer
science almost always you consider just
sum of distances and outside of
theoretical computer science you almost
always consider the sum of distance
squared so I'm going to step outside I'm
going to consider some of distance
squared now the distance grade has some
very nice properties for instance as in
linear algebra least squares fit we'll
see in a minute and that's one reason to
consider mathematically it's nicer to
consider distance squared I'll have
pictures not on the same slide than the
next slide for instance so hopefully
that'll focus some of your attention now
it would have been wonderful if I could
find the exact optimum okay that would
actually solve that would dispense with
the need for this talk or any lots of
papers on the subject but unfortunately
many headaches would be gone if we can
exactly optimize
but unfortunately exact optimization
then P HOD if you're not familiar with
what np-hard is it's very unlikely that
we would have an efficient algorithm we
don't have one now it's very unlikely we
would have one for solving this problem
ever exactly so we have to settle for
approximate optimization and that's
going to create a lot of trouble for us
okay that's one of the reasons actually
for this talk of for many things in the
subject okay here is it just a little
picture to focus our mind here's a
problem with K equals five five clusters
I'm given points on the plane that's all
I can draw and I I wasn't given the
colors
that's the clustering the algorithm or
whatever has come up with these colors
of lue cluster green cluster and so on I
know what to call it color but anyway so
these are five clusters here and I put
down for each cluster a center the plus
mark that's what cluster Center you take
each point in its distance for the
cluster center and square it and some
that's what you do in k-means and you
want to minimize that now one slide I
would have normally put up but I presume
it's completely obvious is that
clustering has a lot of applications so
I should have put up the areas in which
clustering has applications instead this
we rhetorically just asked what area
does clustering not have applications to
it really have applications a lot of
areas so I won't put it up but the
ultimate goal in all the applications is
to find the correct clustering corrected
red now that's the ultimate goal but
there are differences of view as to what
the correct clustering is there are
three our view points that I want to
stress in this talk the first is very
Racal computer science says well the
optimal clustering is obviously the
correct one right maybe I cannot find it
but that is the right one okay now
statistics says the clustering correct
clustering is the one used by the
invisible hand this is like the
invisible hand in economics in a minute
you'll see what it is but it's the data
generator so there's a model of data and
the invisible hand generates the data
and gives it to you and whatever the
invisible hand used whatever cluster
used to generate the data in the first
place is the correct clustering
in a few slides we'll see models that
sort of shed more light on this basic
statement but here's the most
interesting definition of clustering
which is from the practitioner the
practitioner says to hell with you give
me their answer and I'll tell you
whether it's correct or not post facto
now then I mean this sounds unfair but
it's really actually fair because I mean
how would you tell if you're a biologist
what is the correct clustering you want
the correct clustering you cannot you
know I area prior i define the correct
clustering and that is actually a basic
problem at evaluating clustering at all
because you don't know what the correct
answer is until you go and confront the
app so this is I'd know I got a picture
of the invisible hand I'm lazy to draw
pictures but you can download them this
is supposed to be a blackjack table by
the way so okay so what did theoretical
computer science to the lot of effort
has gone into developing approximate
algorithms for k-means clustering or
father other criteria and the reason is
the exact one is not solvable now I will
provide a history of all the sort of
achievements or papers all along these
lines except I want to mention some of
the ultimate ones which are actually
quite simple so it wasn't so simple all
the time but the final final papers are
quite simple so it's easier to mention
so here is the slide of what we know
roughly at the current state of
knowledge some of these or maybe eight
or nine years old for spectral methods
they are quite old
and I'll tell you what they are they are
going to play a big role in this talk
spectral methods yield a solution with
k-means at most a constant times optimal
and to tell you what a basic spectral
method is here will happen in the next
slide but on this slide I want to say
what theory has done over and beyond
this constant factor so here the error
is constant factor times the optimal
that error can be made pretty small
epsilon times the optimal for any
positive epsilon so relative error
epsilon they are now available for for
instance for k-means and over time they
become very simple
in fact they are simple enough that the
idea of this I'll be able to describe in
this slide and this is you - Kumar
suburb wall and sentence about eight or
nine years ago but it's really based on
a series of developments due to these
authors and many more authors actually
so here's what this here was this fatso
I want to get an epsilon approximation
it gets it in linear time very fast when
K is constant so the time dependence is
exponential in K so if the number of
clusters grows we are in trouble but one
assertion is in a lot of applications
case small you have many points maybe
millions of points maybe in hundreds of
dimensions but the number of clusters
you see is thirty let's say so K is
thirty right K small so this is
reasonable what does this algorithm do
it's based on a couple of simple
observations that I want to get across I
won't get you of course the details of
the algorithm but just to see what the
simple ideas are so the starting idea is
extremely simple to get the center of
one cluster so I want to figure out for
each cluster the center one remark
that's useful to have is once I know the
center of the clusters then I'm done
because I put every point to the center
that it's closest to right so if I have
the center's I'm done okay so the object
is to partition I said in clustering it
really is enough to find the center's so
to get the center one cluster let's see
how we can do it one little fact I
should have told you is the centroid is
the correct center it's not very
difficult to see you write sum of
squares is minimized when I take the
centroid of the points as a center
that's a little calculation but that's
all it is right now I want to get the
centroid of a lot of points in a cluster
little observation you have to calculate
to make sure this correct is that
centroid of a small random sample is a
good approximation to the centroid of
the whole cluster good in the sense of
the k-means cost so in principle this is
intuitively obvious you have to do a
calculation to make sure that that's
correct so I can get the center of one
cluster
if only you gave me a random sample of
points from that cluster what's the rub
here what's the problem why couldn't I
always do this well the problem is I
don't know which points belong to a
cluster so I cannot sample and hope to
get points from just one cluster my
sample will contain points from all
clusters i and i don't i cannot
differentiate them right but here's what
they say to solve that problem you take
a random sample of all data that's all
you can do you have no labeling as so in
in the machine learning setup this is
unlabeled learning unsupervised learning
you don't have labels as to what where
points belong to which clusters
otherwise you would be done so you take
a random sample of all data surely that
contains a subset from the largest
cluster it may not contain a very good
subset from small clusters because they
are too small to be sampled but
certainly from the largest cluster it
would contain enough points to suffice
for this estimate okay but I don't know
what those points are right I only have
a sample I know some subset came from
one cluster I don't know which subset
otherwise I'd be done well let's try all
subsets now I should say this seemingly
trivial idea that you don't know which
subset defines in this case a cluster
but in other problems other things and
you try all subsets because you need to
try only small subsets played a big role
there are several algorithms for
instance for the maximum cut problem
that are based on such simple I'd
starting idea so you just try all
subsets pretend that the subset is from
the same cluster okay find the center
right then you peel off the cluster
close to the centroid of that subset and
then you repeat well you won't
necessarily be correct because you
pretended it belonged to the same
cluster but it may not have but if
you're wrong no problem one of the one
of your attempts will be correct and you
will measure them against each other
just by measuring the k-means and you'll
get the right one so this is sometimes
known this kind of technique is
sometimes known as exhaustive
enumeration where you pick a sample and
try all subsets and you know which one
for each one how good it is and then you
take the best one
now this cannot go beyond constant size
subscripts because of the enumeration
unfortunately it cannot do that so it's
easy to see with some calculations that
you cannot beat a constant factor so you
cannot beat a small constant factor in
other words I cannot make this epsilon
go to zero the epsilon remains a small
constant and we'll see that that's going
to cause us problems we need it'll turn
out that in a lot of practical examples
we need epsilon going to 0 okay now I
want to introduce spectral clustering
again many of you will be familiar with
this but what I have done try to do here
in two or three slides is given you try
to give you the cleanest or simplest
presentation of it which we know by now
we didn't actually happen upon this in
the beginning the field as a whole we
have very complicated descriptions and
now what we have here is a very simple
description hopefully you find that so
let's say that there are n data points
the each of them is a vector remember
and we want it closed for them they
ignore the picture for a minute the
k-means clustering wants you to find k
cluster centers call them C 1 through CN
and I'm sorry there are K cluster
centers and you make C 1 through CN C 1
is the cluster Center for a 1 and so on
each of these needs to be one of the
centers that you've found and you want
to minimize the sum of squared distances
between AI and CI ok now I don't know
how to solve this from this is np-hard
but here's a similar problem that I can
in fact solve and a lot of you will
recognize what the solution is instead
of requiring that the CI each of them be
one of K distinct vectors if the CI were
one of K distinct vectors the rank of
the matrix C I put down each CI 0 the
rank is K right so instead relax the
condition constraint to say that the
rank of C is at most K it's for having K
distinct rows let's see what this buys
us well if if you know your linear
algebra you know that these vices
immediately in efficient algorithms this
is Jeff singular value decomposition or
principal component analysis as we'll
see in a minute right so then just
face fine by CI is so what does this say
I want to rank K matrix so that the sum
of squared distances is minimized but
that's a least squares fit k dimensional
subspace least squares fit is just what
it means in calculus that is I take the
sum of squared distances and take the
minimum right just like in calculus the
least squares fit line right so here you
take the perpendicular distance whistles
space and that is if you recall your
lineage where that can be found by
singular value decomposition or that's
principal component analysis if you
don't recall your lean algebra don't bow
don't worry about it at this point just
remember this picture here is a bunch of
points I've been given here in 3d and
case two this in this picture so I want
to find the best two dimensional fit and
I have tried to show that in this
picture it's the two dimensional plane
whose orthogonal vector whose normal is
V okay so that can be found by linear
algebra few if you don't recall it that
can be found so I can find the best
least squares fit k dimensional subspace
even though I couldn't solve the
original problem I can solve what's
called this relaxation now I should
apologize for some of you familiar with
this area this will be elementary but I
do hope I'll give you something that's
that's new yes I have a question
the okay good so see I have the cluster
centers point I belongs to some cluster
it's Center is CI but the C's are not n
different things there are only K
different things so each cluster Center
will appear many many times
among the CI that clear or
we don't know the CI finding the CI use
the problem finding the CI is the
problem and we don't know how to find
the CI to minimize the sum of squared
distances that same P hot but we do know
how to find the space spanned by CI so
that the distance to the subspace is
minimized squared distance by the way
this only works for squared distance
right least squares it is not possible
it's not a it's in fact np-hard if I
didn't put the word square there it
turns out for square I can find it
because of the magic of linear algebra
okay so again instead of finding the K
cluster centers minimizing the sum of
squared distances PCA found us the K
dimensional subspace minimizing the sum
of distances okay this is it this
expense to principal component analysis
right PCA so the natural next step
intuitively would be I found this space
I project down to it and then cluster
that I project the data down to it and
then cluster there for as good at
drawing pictures I should have drawn a
picture of the projection but you can
just imagine like the picture I showed
you that and all the data is projected
onto the sky dimensional space and the
new cluster okay
now the advantage here is K is smaller
than B so you've gained something by
reducing the dimension and this is the
folklore spectral clustering says that
this works okay does it really work and
we'll see that it works under stochastic
models in America I will formulate the
models and we will see that and in fact
even and there without stochastic models
it works that's more recent stuff but I
want to pause for a few slides from
clustering to talk about the glories of
PCA per se principle component analysis
because that's a very big tool in this
as well as many areas okay now some of
you when you think effective Leslie will
think of a different algorithm and that
is to project repeatedly on the second
eigenvector this is due to Fiedler and
she and Malik for instance used to
stream a segmentation
there's a lot of applications please
forget that algorithm for this
because I'm going to focus on projecting
down to the K dimensional space okay and
one short clustering rather than
repeatedly clustering on one dimensional
projections okay now again I promise you
that I'll formulate a simple property of
PCA which is used to get rid of noise
here it is so you have you have the real
data that lies in a k-dimensional space
you're not given that that's what you
would like to get noise has been added
to it and together they form the matrix
a and that's what you're given so from a
I need to figure out see I need to get
rid of the noise and the spectral
clustering folklore is that if I take a
project to the K dimensional principle
subspace that's going to get me more or
less C right just projecting it to the
PC a subspace is going to get more or
less C okay now is that true and we I
want to say something about it that
simple the state and is true now for a
moment assume that the noise is roughly
equally spread in all directions that
means there's no particular direction so
that a lot of noise is focused in that
direction so the dot product of the
noise vectors with that direction is too
high that would be bad if it's true for
one direction suppose that's not true
then in fact the following turns out to
be the case and it's not important
exactly what the numbers are but I want
to remark qualitatively on this it turns
out then you can prove that the error of
PCA that's a bar is supposed to
approximate C right a bar is supposed to
approximate the real data that error is
at most K over D times the total noise
error so what does it mean that means
when K is very here is they actual okay
so this is the actual inequality AI bar
or the data points projections they are
supposed to approximate the true data CI
and the sum of squares is that most this
is noise the sum of noise squares but
times K over D and that's a big win if K
is much less than T this is the
essential use of pca right if K is
much smaller than Diaz in fact in a lot
of applications that is then this is
much better now I want to spend a one
slide telling you formally for those of
you in the audience who know all about
norms just to say what this statement
really is and give you a lemma and again
sort of remark that it was not always as
simple but denoising is formally stated
and proved usually with a lot of
assumptions but really it's a very
simple m up with a 5-line proof once I
give you the lemma you can go home and
prove it but we didn't actually arrive
at this lemma so clean lemma so easily
took us some while maybe not everyone
but it took at least as summarized
there's a lemma this actually the first
proof is due to a clerk doesn't make
sharee the proofs the sort of longer
here's a proof I have with Hopcroft so
the statement is this you have any
matrix and you're projected to it's K
dimensional principal subspace and C is
any matrix with a low rank then the
following is true on the left hand side
you have the error when you take the
projection - true data right but you
take F here which is a sum of squares of
all the increase the Frobenius norm on
the right hand side is a spectral law
that is this is just this - sub - here
denotes the maximum overall unit length
vectors of this so what this is really
saying intuitively is on the left hand
side you have a d-dimensional distances
the full space on the right hand side
here only one-dimensional distances so
the error in all of the dimensions is
that most of small constant times the
error in one dimension in any one
direction that's what this lemma is
saying and once you have this lemma in
front of you it's very easy to prove I
want to remark on one fact that's quite
striking about this as well as other
things I'm going to say you took a and
found one projection a bar right and
some of the assertions is for any C this
is true so you're a bar is close to C
for any C at all
now how can that be right that is so
because for Bad Seeds there are a lot of
infinitely many C's but for many C's
this is very large the right hand side
so the inequality is not saying anything
useful so in fact this is true for every
see even though you found just one
production so let me recall one more
time project and cluster project data
points to the space spanned by the
topcase singular vectors and then you do
an approximate projection in the class
approximate clustering in the projection
and here you use all the machinery
developed by theoretical computer
science ok if data was generated by a
mixture model and we'll see what this is
now in a minute if data was generated by
a stochastic model then this words in
fact even if data was not generated by a
stochastic model we'll see that
this provides a good start for what's
called the k-means algorithm from which
we get rapid convergence now so excuse
me so I want to pause for a minute from
clustering say something about PCA and
we'll back to clustering I'll do that a
couple of times so here's a general
question so PCA is not only used for
clustering it's used for a lot of things
one can ask can we do something
efficient about carrying out PCA usually
it's an N cubed algorithm if you want to
do it straightly but can we do better so
one question that's come up maybe about
10 15 years ago is can we not work on
the whole matrix instead draw a
subsample of the matrix pick a few rows
and columns and do PCA only on the
sample is that going to tell us anything
about the whole matrix and now in 95 we
came up with an algorithm where we said
we can in fact do that if we pick rows
and columns with probability
proportional to the square of their
length it turns out these probabilities
again the square here is the same kind
of reason as the mathematical niceness
of least squares fit ten of these are
not practical these require very high
polynomial times in terms of the error
bounds right but if you attended some of
the workshops in this Big Data semester
you would have seen a decade of
development by many people
two of the people who did this and who
also organised workshops
Petronius Mahoney presented sampling
this presented methods and with the
final result or with the result today
that they could say sampling based
methods are now a crucial ingredient of
computing with large matrices
okay so solitaire originally wasn't so
good in in terms of practicality but it
was improved and it's now at a stage
where it's quite a staple now one result
out of this slot I would like to really
emphasize his due to Clausen in Woodruff
and this is very nice self-contained
result and I want to state that it gives
you nearly the best approximation
low-rank approximation to a can be found
in linear time where time is linear in
the number of nonzero entries okay now
often the matrix matrices you see big
matrices or sparse they are very few non
zeros so you want running times in terms
of that and in terms of that this is
linear and that's based on a beautiful
idea called subspace embeddings which is
a self-contained statement here that
they prove clocks and woodruff proof
which I like to draw your attention to
so it says the following if you have a
random matrix which is R by n R is much
smaller than n and by the way is a
dimensional array now the matrix is just
one entry per column which is plus or
minus one chosen at random then
simultaneously for all vectors that's
very important or infinitely many
vectors X and for every one of them
simultaneously the length of s times a
times X approximates the length of X
length of a X so whatever you were going
to do with a you could do with s times a
which is much smaller that's the moral
of this story
and indeed the point that A's s is so
sparse is very helpful now that took
some time to come to it was a conclusion
of many other results but I won't state
all there is us but this is very simple
to state this is a random it's called
subspace I'm betting it's a random
subspace embedding
now I won't say more about this but now
I want to go to the statistical models
by drawing some pictures here so I want
to introduce mixture models from
Statistics what our mixture models
they're models that they're models of
probability densities probability
density is defined in high dimensional
space in this picture I'm defining it on
the plane okay there are this in this
picture is a mixture of four simple
Gaussian densities the red the yellow
the green and the blue each of them is a
Gaussian you weight the densities and
add them that's your mixture right and
what I've drawn in the plane is samples
according to that mixture right so it's
a probability density on to space and
the vertical dimension is the is the
probability density more formally here
is a mixture model it's a density on D
space that's a weighted sum of simple
probability densities like the Gaussian
okay so you weight them a non-negative
numbers coming to one you add them up
it's a weighted convex combination of
those densities now the mixture model
hypothesizes the data points or n iid
samples where you pick each sample
according to the mixture
so for each sample you pick one of these
guys with the right weights and pick
from that density right and that's how
excuse me that's how these points were
picked right so you pick the red density
with a certain weight and then infect a
point from that they lie a lot of points
lie about the mean of that red density
okay so this is probably the most
important picture of the slide so let me
spend a minute on that is it an
extremely simple picture but it is very
important so here is a picture of two
nefarious gaussians actually this is
going to be something you should test
all your algorithms on in some sense is
what I'm going to say you have two
gaussians in d space their standard
deviation is Sigma in each direction
each direction but you're living in D
space now in these face the distance to
a data point from the center is route T
times Sigma
it's Pythagoras theorem so there are
three dimensions the squares add up the
variances add up so the standard
deviation is Sigma the variance of Sigma
Squared's add up so you are a distance
root D Sigma here's a second Gaussian
Center separated by a few Sigma's and
those points are at root T Sigma what's
bad about these two thousands is their
points are very far from the center
compared to the compared to the distance
between the gaussians right so the main
squared distance for a point from the
center is d times Sigma squared
but the inter Center separation is only
a few Sigma's okay now if I did
approximate clustering that I'm doing
k-means I'm measuring squared distances
if I did approximately I can make an
error of epsilon times T times Sigma
squared for a point right and that's
very bad because that allows me to put a
lot of points from this cluster along
with this cluster and still be right
according to this criterion right the
error is too much the correct error we
should allow is in terms of Sigma but we
are allowing error in terms of D times
Sigma squared okay I should have drawn a
picture well you can imagine these
gaussians projected to one dimension if
I project them to them to the one
dimensional axis then they become nice
because they become gaussians with Sigma
is the standard deviation there's no
routine there's no D D goes away so they
look nice yeah but that picture I didn't
put up so here now is something that
probably all of you are familiar with in
one dimension if you have 2,000 so
standard deviation one each
if the inter Center separation is a many
standard deviations you can tell them
apart if it's far less than one over 100
standard deviations of course you cannot
tell them apart
if it's 0 they collapse can you say
something like this for D dimensions
well it seems that you should be able to
it was not that simple there's a
beautiful result of M Palembang maybe
about 15 12 years back we said in fact a
similar result holds for D dimensions if
you have not even just two but a
constant number of spherical Gaussian so
standard deviation one each and the
separation between centers is at least a
constant so the mnemonic for this part
of the talk is means separated by a few
standard deviations you know you
normally here are six standard
deviations I'm going to allow a constant
number of standard deviations right
any big constant well constants are even
that's a little bit bigger than constant
if the intercept Center separation is at
least this then you can tell them apart
in fact we could correctly cluster each
data point and you do this by PCA in a
way that I probably won't tell you but
basically what I said spectral
clustering was for this and the argument
is very nice and very simple now okay so
this now is a little more philosophical
part so this is trying to explain why in
practice np-hard problems seem to be
solved and practitioners merrily solve
them and go on and white ferret issues
maybe have to reconcile with that so
here's one reconciliation that people
have attempted so practitioners often
saw the empty hard problems with
heuristics and seemed quite happy hi
okay perhaps when the solution is table
it's easy to find and here's a notion of
stability that's been studied
extensively in TCS well I wouldn't say
extensively but to some extent in TCS
much more needs to be done
okay this was formulated by velu and
natty lineal so here's a statement for a
different problem for Mac Scott the
optimal solution to Mac Scott they say
is stable if if you arbitrarily change
edge weights by a certain factor Delta
each right then the solution doesn't
change it still leaves this solution as
the optimal solution so you can ask for
what values of so if Delta is very large
it's a very very strong condition even
if I change weights by a lot the
solution doesn't change so you can say
I'd like to make Delta as small as
possible and still live with it for what
values of Delta can you find stable
solutions it's only known for very high
values of Delta at this point Delta
greater than root n it'd be more
interesting to bring it down more closer
to
this talk for clustering you can
formulate a similar notion and I'll have
a picture in the next slide again to
explain these notions a bit but Balkan
Blum and Gupta formulated this notion
optimal k-means clustering is stable if
any near optimal clustering near optimal
means the value is close differs from C
in a small fraction of objects so if the
value is close then the clustering is
also close that's what it says that you
have to rearrange only a few points and
so if there are stable solutions they
gave some algorithms to find them so did
Daniel II naughty and Mike Sachs
and various other algorithms are also
known for this now there are related
definitions of stability by a series of
authors and they are roughly roughly
similar but slightly different so this
is a very interesting promising approach
and there are many questions but here is
the problem for the notorious two
Gaussian picture the correct solution is
not stable now before I talk about that
here is a picture sort of a schematic
diagram of what stability means right so
this plane here is the space of
clusterings so there are lots of
clustering so each clustering has a
value which is in the vertical axis the
third dimension okay
the value is the k-means objective
function value the stability says there
is a unique minimum this clustering
that's a stable solution so that as the
value increases that clusterings also go
apart right so if the value is close
another way of saying that if the value
is close in the vertical axis then the
clustering is close so in some sense is
the unique best clustering and you
really go away from it very fast okay it
stands out as a clustering and then the
assertion is you can find it now
unfortunately what happens in the two
means Gaussian that that that example I
showed you is that the k-means value is
so large that miss clustering points
Changez relatively little of the value
so many clusterings have roughly the
same value so they're actually the third
dimension that's more or less flat the
vertical axis looks more or less flat so
it's rather different from this picture
so we now what I'm now going to do is
try to repair this I want to formulate a
notion of stability that works for the
two Gaussian case as well as in things
we know and that's a notion of proper so
let me define this it's it's a simple
natural definition so we say a
clustering is proper if it's variance
now we don't measure the k-means sum of
distance quake instead we measure the
max over all the right directions view
of the mean squared distance so I don't
measure distances in the whole space I
measure it per direction right that's
the way to think about it so this is
variance in one direction and that s be
optimal but also the inter cluster
separation is at least a constant times
Sigma again the mnemonic is the means or
six standard deviations apart okay but
the means are apart only in the
projection right we don't care about the
whole space and the two Gaussian picture
satisfies this definition of stability
and in fact under this stability also
you can find the optimal solution so if
there is a proper clustering C star if
there is a stable clustering in this
sense then in fact project and cluster
finds it points nearly that it's off by
a fraction of points but otherwise it
finds it and the mixture model satisfies
proper clustering this really is sort of
falls out of a hardier theorem which I
probably won't explain but let me say
let me read it and then say what it is
before going on to the next topic it is
if there is a clustering C star such
that when data points are projected to
the space of centers each projected data
point is closer to its own Center than
any other Center by at least a few
Sigma's then project and cluster gives
you a good start when you follow that by
Lloyds are my
is something that many of you know if
you don't know if there is a few minutes
I will try to explain I have some
pictures otherwise for the moment just
assume let me have said that it's one of
the most used algorithms and practice in
fact it proves convergence of this
algorithm for why did you start with the
spectral clustering centers yeah that's
right so we are doing spherically
symmetric there is actually interesting
question whether it extends to general
gaussians but that I didn't formulate it
but that's another good question okay so
maybe I'll skip Lloyd's algorithm and
come back to it I will tell you one
thing I want that got some nice pictures
but maybe we should go to this so in the
main there are two dimensional reduction
techniques that we know there are many
variations but there are two things we
know one is this PCA it projects high
dimensional data points into the best
fit linear space it's used in practice a
lot but clustering is probably one area
where we have proved so its efficacy
proofs that it gives you right answers
other areas we don't generally have
proofs in theory we use a lot the random
projection method that's as a dimension
reduction and the random projection in
fact it's used a lot for nearest
neighbor
this stands for nearest neighbor search
which is just I've given a bunch of
points the query point arrives you have
to tell me what is this nearest point
it's a big problem it's solved as a
probably one of the most used
subroutines so there's a lot of work on
that and what you do is randomly project
down to a lower dimensional space and
there you can prove things PCA you
cannot prove things
it remains an interesting question
whether you can actually prove more
things about PCA than this especially
for nearest neighbor search where PCA is
used a lot in practice with not many
proofs office efficacy I want to spend
the last little bit on what is perhaps
an extreme to extreme theory you might
call it is an attempt to form a set of
axioms which tell you what is the
correct list
okay so we struggled with this and here
is something that Kleinberg attempted
you say that clustering criterion such
as k-means what does it do in the
abstract it gives you a mapping that
says if you give me pairwise distances I
give you an optimal clustering for that
criterion right now this is on the lines
of if you're familiar with arrows
theorem this is attempting to be on the
lines of arrows theorem and
unfortunately with the same conclusion a
system of reasonable axioms any
clustering criterion ought to satisfy it
seems to be these are reasonable here
are three things that plane by put-down
consistency if we increase distances
between points in different clusters and
decrease distances between points in the
same cluster the optimal clustering
should still remain optimal so I find
the optimal curse ring then I take the
clusters and say distances between two
points and same cluster perhaps I reduce
them distances between points in
different lists as I increase them it
should be even more optimal right so it
should remain optimal at least you have
to worry a little bit about theis there
might be multiple optimal solution let's
not worry about that for the minute
scale invariance another reasonable
property which says multiply all the
senses by the same constant it should
leave the optimal clustering the same
that seems obviously true and the third
property is richness he says for any of
T now how many partitions of K points
endpoints are there in the K sets K to
the N for any of those there's some
distance function for which that is the
correct optimal partition now there's no
bound on K here so you can partition an
any number of things and then that
should be the optimal clustering and
then Kleinberg proved as I let you let
it out earlier that there's no
clustering satisfying all these criteria
all these axioms and you can say whoops
and the answer is actually not oops
these these things are too rich these
axioms they're not something that you
ought to require of all reasonable
criteria and here is a here's a set of
axioms which is feasible and it's just
actually a translation of these axioms
with the added assumption
that things are in Euclidean space right
so these are abstract distances which
satisfy triangle inequality they can be
any distances there's no necessarily
realization in Euclidean space so if you
just assume that it's realizable
including space it turns out a very
simple actually natural criterion
becomes becomes correct
so we insist on the points being in
Euclidean space there is a criterion
satisfying the axioms consistency same
thing that is if we found the out filter
string then the more points or the
existence for points in its own cluster
decreases and two points in different
clusters increases the optimal pestering
should still remain optimal scale
invariance is the same thing you
multiply all distances by the same
constant it should leave the optimal
clustering still optimal richness now we
have to require that things belong to
Euclidean space so in the old set up end
points could be partitioned in K to the
N ways if you know you are theory of a
picture with anchors dimension that is
not possible with Euclidean space you
can't partition into so many possible
partitions right so here's what the
requirement for any set of K points
there's some placement that makes them
the Centers and then the theorem is that
balance came in so we modify came in
slightly that you want to minimize the
sum of distance squared but you want to
keep the cluster sizes the same to
cluster centers among all partitions
into K clusters each with the n over K
points does satisfy all these axioms now
I this I don't know a lot more about
this it'll be interesting to find out
maybe though the questions on that but I
think I'll stop here I have reserved
slides in case we run out of questions
for time or run into extra time but we
probably want
right yeah that's a good question the
reason is that if I take the sum of
squares of all pairwise distances that
some factor times the sum of distance
quoits to the center but the fact that
depends on a number in each cluster and
this proof crucially uses the numbers
are equal so that I can relate I can
like instead of taking distance to the
cluster Center I could take all pairwise
distances squared and sum them up so
that's possible I don't know the answer
it would be nice to do that that we
could for the ordinary one I don't know
the answer to that so some of the
cluster centers or a derivative concept
where as pair were all pairwise
distances or a given concept so that
seems to be the issue
it's a good question I don't know the
precise answer I'd love to think about
the proof I may be using but it would be
nice actually not to use all of your
collision power leaflet in your right so
I don't know the answer
okay well I think the final answer is
that the answer wants to be yes of
course right but see I think that
complaint
sometimes practical or people might have
against theory is that we focus on some
definite criteria and don't stare out of
that for instance we focus on K median
instead of k-means or we focus on
constant factors and approximation and
we saw that those things are not very
good on the other hand all the theory
developed if you slightly modify it use
this projection or whatever modification
then we need to use all the
approximation algorithms in the
projection so the theory is very useful
focusing on a few criteria focuses the
mind so theory gets developed but I
think we have to adapt it a little bit
so that's the answer that we have to be
ready to adapt a little bit
thank you